je sais pas si vous avez remarqué sur
snapfish attaché à sa à oui oui j'ai
déménagé c'est pas vrai en fait c'est un
décor autour est absolument rien ne
marche même pas alors pour les dieux qui
regarde cette vidéo snapshot qu'est ce
que c'est c'est une application qui
permet d'envoyer des messages des photos
ou des vidéos qui dure que quelques
secondes même si vous êtes dieu vous
pouvez la télécharger un suffit de taper
snk chat face2face chat et c'est bon la
technique anti-vieux si un peu
déroutante nachat au début pourquoi
envoyer une photo qui sera supprimée
ensuite la photographie c'est c1 mars et
le 8e art ça raconte quelque chose c'est
noble et voilà je suis fier de vous
présenter mon chef-d'oeuvre
ça vous a plu vous voulez qu'on en parle
c'est marrant sur snapshot ya souvent
une différence entre le snap que tu
envoies à quelqu'un du même sexe genre
ton pote et le snap et envoie à
quelqu'un du sexe opposé
genre une meuf que tu veux c'est chaud
c'est bizarre ce comportement sur ce
match at on n'est pas comme ça dans la
vraie vie
[Musique]
même tous recevoir un snap un petit peu
mignon voire un peu coquin même
uniquement qu'aucun ça suffit quand un
pote en reçoit à côté de toi tu as envie
de voir
[Musique]
à trop tard désolé allez salut
o la meuf je vais faire comme les cinq
tweet à éviter sur twitter je vous livre
mais ça le truc qui m'énerve sur ce top
le snap de l'artiste peint je reçois
parfois des snap avec des dessins de ouf
le mec a passé des heures et quand j'ai
comparé avec les miens je me sens
totalement nulle tranquillement le mec
avec son doigt est plus douée que toi
avec toute la papeterie de la planète
alors quand je reçois ça je ne réponds
pas comme ça le mec qui pète un câble et
m'a fallu trois heures pour ceusses
nappe tu peux me répondre - oui je suis
un connard
4 tu peux choisir la durée de ton snap
je ne comprends pas ce qui laisse la
durée maximale pour un snap qui n'a
aucun intérêt
pourquoi pourquoi ton chat mérite 10
secondes
il peut se passer plein de trucs en 10
secondes vous êtes en état d'arrestation
vous pouvez vous tromper janot sauvé la
vie merci beaucoup
regardez trop nombreux on va mourir
allô maman allez on suit ta mère en fait
les choses par eux-mêmes en trois on
peut savoir qui a fait un screenshot de
ton snap ça c'est une fonctionnalité
super intéressante et ya des gens qui
font des screenshots de tout ce que tu
fais à quoi ça sert sérieux je
collectionne les photos des gens je les
imprime et gillet met dans ma bouche
2 alors il ya ceux qui font des snap
inutile de 10 secondes et à l'inversé
ceux qui font des snap d'une seconde tu
as le temps de voir quoi exactement on
une seconde tu t'es cru dans un jeux de
mémorisation c'est ça heureusement que
les snacks d'une seconde sont souvent
des photos de beats finalement six fours
chaque j'ai fait des screenshots un
peut-être le truc qui m'énerve le plus
sûr snapshots et quand je reçois une
vidéo courte mais que je suis en
silencieux
j'espère que ce n'était pas intéressant
je critique pas ma snapshot mais c'est
quand même mortel parfois je reçois des
stats mémorable de mes potes on se tape
des barres de ouf
d'ailleurs vous pouvez rajouter sur snap
c'est cyprien vidéo tout simplement bon
par contre comment parler de snapshot
sans évoquer la plus grande phobie de
tous les utilisateurs de l'application
on a tous peur qu'un jour en fait depuis
le début on gardait toutes les photos
d'ailleurs à partir de maintenant elles
sont disponibles sur internet
allez salut
abonne toi si tu as envie si tu veux pas
tu fais comme tu veux
c'est vraiment comme tu le sens j'ai dit
ça comme ça j'ai un dernier petit mot
concernant ma précédente vidéo
j'ai été très maladroit en suggérant que
les roms étaient des voleurs je regrette
d'avoir dit ça c'était vraiment une
bêtise de ma part j'ai jamais voulu
attiser la haine dans mes vidéos c'est
même le strict inverse je ne veux pas
stigmatiser les gens ou une population
je veux juste que tout le monde rigole
énormément j'ai fait une erreur et
j'espère que vous ne le ferez pas je
compte sur vous